so just have a short
rest my hip my right
hip I don't do with that with my foot
because my foot might not get there at
the right time so what I do now is I
push it with my I push my right hip
forward like that as if it's got weight
to it and it then because it's going
through it's wide all through my body it
sort of like throws the Ken right so if
you like the Ken's cut is a whiplash of
that
hip then you go cool I enjoyed that you
I mean it's it starts
to it start apart from look this fat
belly that
sadly well I know if we all get it when
we get older but we don't train enough
but um the power is still exciting for
me because it's like I'm even though I'm
doing it I'm experiencing ing the joy of
this Oneness if you like you do this
exercise you know and you think why do
we do that I do this it's like yes I'll
get somewhere with this one day but but
it's very difficult to get somewhere you
know you're always searching but when
you do get
this you know it starts to become you
know wor while getting your keny on I
used to before I used to go to bed every
uh for years and years before I went to
bed I used to have this near the back
door and um I used to go oh I'm going to
bed the last thing I want to be doing
isy I'm ready for bed you'd never sleep
would you so what I used to do is I used
to get it and
go
I used to do it three times put it away
and that way I could just go out of bed
comfortable because I I didn't try but
what I was looking for was the
timing this is not the timing step cut
foot back lift step forward cut you see
so I was looking for if you like the
piece of going to bed
and enjoying going to bed knowing that I
was getting closer to being in harmony
you
know
and we're trying to get in harmony with
ourself all the time in
iido um you could become paranoid
about
how uncoordinated we are you know we
walk around with ourselves 24/7 yet
we're very clumsy you know a teach just
say put your right foot leg forward and
your and and your right arm you go like
that and he goes yeah and the other
right leg oh sorry you know I mean I
used to do it it's quite a beginner's
thing so we're quite
clumsy at what we do so what I'm trying
to teach you tonight is not just seven
suburi but
[Applause]
why why you're doing it for enjoyment
not just to say oh I know I got to swing
the Ken and do seven
subur now the next one the second one
it's just an add on to the first so this
is the
first but when it goes to about here all
I got to do is instead of bringing my
foot back to
here and dropping it down here and then
forward again I just bypass that foot
and it goes
up and then it comes back
you see it's peaceful you you add P
power will come what you what's wrong
with I know especially men what's wrong
with us men is we put Power in through
the mind you know we we put Power and we
go
yes you know and again it's uh it's you
will never find it you'll never find
those sense as I could i s to sense he
told me that when I first met
[Music]
him I'll go into it a bit deeper in a
minute all right
okay please try you can only do your
best so that's all I'm asking you to
do don't don't try too hard you
know it's your best not doing it for my
best and up like this up tip tip up then
as the foot turns it then
drops and then that
hip breathe out through the mouth in
through the
nose as you lift out through the mouth
stop start the breath before the cup
keep your head St
straighter